I'm Kate I'm a video producer at
GameSpot I don't know anything about dog
cells and I'm gonna have a go at
guessing the bosses from the first two
games okay that's the guy from Star Wars
the guy with the with the teeth that
gets crushed
yeah yeah does that does he have people
on top of him it's like dancing like do
Saturday Night Fever okay so he's
clearly a disco pumpkin oh that guy's
nice I like him I actually really like
that coat that she's wearing although
that might be her skin
oh that's that's just like would you
throw something right tell me what's
done with her face he's like the
embodiment of mac makeup I don't know
but it looks like a grandma like he's
got a little shawl on he's going oh
Michael could you turn the stove on
please Jillian here okay so that's a
mirror shield from Legend of Zelda he's
got very simple name it's it's pretty
much say what you see with this guy
gladiator mirror gladiator very nice
mirror link that guy is spinal issues
she's like he looks pretty well armored
so I wouldn't want to fight him he also
looks like he's got a gnome in his
crotch what's he got in his belt it
looks like jammie Dodgers those the
jammies it's no biscuit Queen that just
looks like a collection of bones yes
okay
was he built by like a a dog or
something that looks like like a
Rorschach test for my nightmares
he's like all bitey it kind of looks
like a Venus flytrap but also that he is
the fly why does he look like an
exploding clothes that's like okay if
you worked a studio ghibli but you hated
your life you draw that is it is the
horse the bad or the man or the bad it's
all the bad all the bad I don't seem
fair what's she holding it's like it's
like a wicked guitar oh are you sure
yes he looks like like a KFC bucket
after you finished it I'm gonna be a
nerd hair and I really hope it works so
he looks like a goat the Latin for go is
cat pro camera demon oh god damn that's
wolf link dentist nightmare whiskers
chesty dragon flaps always got lady
coming out of it I only just noticed
that I thought she was just standing
behind it
Brienne of Tarth he looks really upset
it's just some rocks oh there's a spider
in the middle of it ah
oh don't like that so what I like about
him sasha is that he slashed has a
hammer that could also be a bongo he
looks stupid I can't even see what that
is
oh hello it's kind of like a magical
picture where you like I don't know how
to find anything in this relations Kate
you got one one No